So let's look at a better solution. Because this
should not be a problem that every single developer of
server side applications need to think about. Fortunately the Google
cloud platform has a product that takes care of most
of these things. It's called App Engine, and that's
what we will be using in this course. Let's take
a closer look. App Engine is a development and deployment
platform that takes care of many things for your application.
For example, it performs all the scaling for you
automatically. So when your application runs on App Engine, and
there is more traffic it needs to manage. Then
App Engine will increase the number of instances to use
to take care of the load. This is called
scaling up. And at other times, when your application is
not so busy. App Engine will reduce the number
of instances to save resources and cost. This is called
scaling down. And this scaling is done automatically. You
don't need to write a single line of application code
to get this benefit. And it doesn't stop with automatic
scaling. The App Engine platform has functionality to deal with
all of the things we've previously looked at. So there
is no need for you to do any design or
coding to deal with that. And this is no coincidence.
Google has been the leader in designing scalable systems and
all that experience was built into App Engine
when it was designed. As is everything runs on
Google infrastructure. There are Google engineers watching over
these systems day and night, to make sure everything
is running smoothly. So that you, can focus
on your application. In Cloud language, App Engine is
classified as a PaaS solution. And this makes
sense, because App Engine is a platform that takes
care of a lot of the complexity of building scalable applications